verres bonjour les bombardements russes
se poursuivent un petit peu partout à
travers l'ukraine
oui à part l'offensive qui a lieu dans
l'est il y à des tirs sur ce que les
russes ont apparemment déterminés être
des objets d'infrastructures critiques
ou des objets militaires ces derniers
jours il y a eu des tirs sur gamecube
dans le centre de l'ukraine zaporizhya
dans le centre est une très grande ville
là les russes affirment avoir détruit
une importante quantité d'armes donné à
l'ukraine fourni à l'ukraine par ses
alliés occidental bien sûr ces
informations sont impossibles à vérifier
sinon à part l'infrastructure pétrolière
des dépôts de pétrole qui sont souvent
visés en ukraine ces derniers jours il
ya eu l'infrastructure ferroviaire qui a
été avisé et notamment ce matin une
nouvelle tentative de détruire un pont
routières et ferroviaires dans la région
d'odessa un point très important parce
que cela amène au port de rennes-ii la
porte sur la fleuve du danube pied en ce
moment le seul port d'envergure qui
fonctionne pour exporter le grain
ukrainien avec ismaël un autre port
fluvial voisins ce matin il paraîtrait
que la frappe sur ce pont qui hier il ya
eu une frappe qui n'a pas réussi à
détruire ce pont selon les informations
des autorités locales ce matin les
endommagements à ce pont sera bien plus
importante il par ailleurs admet des
avancées russe à l'est plusieurs
localités aurait été prise
oui ce sont des petits villages mais ce
sont des localités qui témoigne d'un
certain succès ou du moins d'une avancée
pour les russes dans leur tentative
d'encercler les forces ukrainienne et
peut être d'essayer d'encercler les
villes de la viande et des cram à tort
sq de ville grandes villes sous contrôle
l'ukrainienne dans la région de donetsk
que donc il ya eu une avancée vers
l'ouest à partir de zoom est aussi une
avancée
où les forces russes à l'ouest de
rubigen et de crémines à qui contrôlent
avanceraient vers lima n'est donc vers
cela vient ce que c'est uniquement dans
cette partie nord d'une basse où il y a
vraiment des avancées pour le moment les
troupes russes semblent être bloqués
dans leur tentative de pousser vers le
nord à partir de données que même qu'il
contrôle et de prendre ma keep
marica pardon ou à venir qu'à deux
villes sous contrôle crânienne tout près
de donetsk où visiblement les forces
ukrainienne résister empêche les russes
d'avancé merci beaucoup gulliver craque